here with reaction Florida Senator Marco
Rubio senator can you answer the
question is our border secure have we
been lied to for three straightly years
our border is not just unsecure it's a
migratory crisis of of Epic Proportions
but without precedent in American
history this has never happened before
in the history of this country first of
all the administration is lying they
know for a fact that trafficking
networks that have links to terrorist
groups are involved in the trafficking
of people now it's a business that they
have and they move people around the
world and they get them in there but you
tell me that an islamist linked Network
that moves people that are willing to
pay the money isn't also willing to move
terrorists or think about it this way
last year over
900,000 people in a 12-month period
entered the United States illegally and
were released into the country by the
Biden Administration 900,000 people if
just one tenth of 1% of those people are
terrorists that is 900 terrorists that
have crossed the borders and those are
the ones that we actually saw come in
and processed and released into the
country this this border is is wide open
and everybody in the world knows it and
that's why they keep coming and look it
it's anger you know it angers any
country to see people from other places
showing up at your border demanding to
be let in having people in this country
argue that somehow they have a right to
come in and not just have a right to
come in but we have an obligation to now
provide billions of dollars which is
what they're asking for okay in this
whole deal that they're asking for in a
supplemental they're not asking for
money to enforce the law they're asking
for more money to do what they are doing
now in essence waving people in Faster
that's what they're asking for but it is
an unsecure border ac across which
anybody from anywhere in the world can
come and listen maybe some of those
people when they get here have Islamic
sympathies islamist sympathies and
they're not necessarily terrorists they
don't consider themselves that way but
then they come here they see the
headlines they hear the call to action
they get fired up just like people that
are born in this country that are out
there now supporting Hamas imagine
people that already come with that
preconceived uh idea about it being
inspired to a lone wolf attack which is
the number one threat and then the other
threat Sean and I'm sorry to filibuster
be so fired up about it but it's a big
deal is we know for a fact in fact the
FBI director said it today that Iran is
tried to conduct operations inside this
country and we know for a fact that
Hezbollah has invested in the same
capability the ability to attack
Americans here in the Homeland for
assassination for Mass casualties as a
point of Leverage against us just like
these attacks by proxies in the Middle
East as a weapon they have they know
that conducting attacks in the United
States is another weapon they can
threaten us with if they think we're
going to do something to them this is a
serious crisis how is it possible when
may orcus has asked a simple question
after he's been telling us the bord is
closed and secure which he's been lying
about and he's asked a simple question
about how many people he can't answer
that question or John Kirby can't answer
the question I can't possibly know among
the 8 million illegal immigrants we've
allowed in whether people have radical
associations well um didn't they swear
an oath to uphold the rule of law and
our constitution does Joe Biden somehow
have a magical right to enforce only the
laws he agrees with isn't there a
process if you don't like the law you go
through the process of changing the law
they're playing a word game with us the
first thing they're saying is the law is
being complied with what they're arguing
is that we have Asylum law someone
crosses they claim Asylum they claim the
law says we have to let them in we have
to let them stay until they get a court
hearing that many don't show up for so
they're arguing they're following the
law what they're not telling you is
that's how that's how they interpret the
law and how that law is being
interpreted by migrants is look all we
have to do is get into the US say the
magic words we're going to be released
we're going to be released and we're
going to be sent to any City we want to
and they're going to pay for it and and
and that's what's driving this incentive
for people to come and everybody in the
world knows it and the other lie they
keep saying is we have a broken legal
immigration system the the main thing
that's broken about our legal
immigration system is that it is cheaper
and faster and easier to come illegally
than it is to come legally imagine if
you're someone out there that's been
waiting for 10 years Years cuz you
applied for a Visa and you're waiting
but somebody you know came here
illegally and is now maybe even on the
verge of getting residency because they
have some political backing in the
country to grant them a path to
citizenship imagine what a sucker you
feel like that's the the thing that's
broken about our immigration system is
we are incentivizing people to come
illegally and we are refusing this
Administration refuses to enforce the
law and that's why no matter how people
feel about Ukraine people come to us and
say but how can we deal with that
without securing our border first how
can that not be a priority before
anything else that we do and they have
poisoned the well on an important policy
matter because people look at that and
say how can we deal with that until we
deal with this right here at home well
said Senator thank you I hope Americans
are hearing you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else